le paris dakar avec du jamais vu c'est
une femme qui remporte la compétition
c'est aussi la première fois qu'une
pilote arrache la victoire sur un
circuit l'allemand de jutta kleinschmidt
sur mitsubishi a laissé sur le côté lors
de la dernière spéciale les favoris le
français jean louis schlesser ayant été
pénalisé par les commissaires de la
course
christelle bertrand remy poissonnier
pour la première fois le dakar change de
genre
cette année il est féminin jutta
kleinschmidt remporté son premier rallye
raid après une course mouvementée
personne n'aurait pu prédire sa victoire
même pas elle c'est à mes yeux nous
avons beaucoup de chance parce que
normalement nouveau tu as le maillot de
santos est cause nous sommes la première
passion c'est la moto 22e en 94 elle se
rend vite compte des progrès qui lui
reste à faire alors elle change de
véhicules 96 c'est la rencontre avec
jean louis schlesser utah pilotes alors
un buggy mais ces deux fortes
personnalités se sépare en 98
l'allemande signe ensuite chez
mitsubishi et se classe troisième du
dakar
cette année la rivalité schlesser klein
schmidt s'est exprimée plusieurs fois
dans le désert jusqu'au bout le français
ne s'avouent pas vaincus bon bah bon
l'appel quand tu auras la peine au
moment il ya un appel qui courent mais
utah est quand même sacré première à 36
ans l'allemande succèdent h les serres
au palmarès
jutta kleinschmidt on est presque tout
retourné à moto le vainqueur est tout
aussi surprenant fabrizio meoni un des
pilotes les plus malchanceux ces
dernières années remporte enfin son
premier dakar
l'italien succède au français richard 5
il peut enfin se laisser aller à
exprimer l'émotion la fatigue des
souvenirs c'est bien normal après onze
mille kilomètres